beautiful day here in the gateway city
it is cool that is windy
but no rain in the forecast we had some
rain during our
game two yesterday
it is 63 degrees and with brad thompson
jim hayes i'm dan mclaughlin we're
delighted that you're with us the rubber
game between
the saint louis cardinals and the
milwaukee brewers
well daniel ponce de leon on the mound
for the cardinals today in this rubber
game five innings three hits one run one
walk lorenzo kane steps in the box and
first pitch
takes a swing deep left field this one
to the warning track and
off the wall it looks like
and lorenzo kane will open up with a
double in this game jumping on that
first pit so runner in scoring position
right out of the gates for daniel
vogelback
this one rolled into right field the
base hit and lorenzo kane comes around
and scores the brewers first run of the
game well done first two in the batting
order that's a great council pushing the
right buttons getting volga back in the
lineup and hitting him right behind kane
vogelback brought in lorenzo kane with
an rbi single
and now it's garcia's turn
and this one hammered into left field
way
back into that bullpen a home run for
avi garcia his second of the season and
milwaukee now out in front three to
nothing pretty much the same pitch that
he hit out in yesterday's game
fastball middle in and he did not miss
it boy he's starting to heat up
good to see the brewers
jump on the cardinals right away
balling a strike
and this one looked it into center field
and it falls in and it gets past lane
thomas carlson there to pick it up
travis shaw will go to third manny a
stand-up double
and the lefty brett anderson
loves seeing that very cool i want to
like him before we start this game now
you gotta like him you gotta put a
hurting on this guy you're already in a
hole and then we show him making a kid's
day
what are we doing here that kid will
never forget that that's what that's how
it should be yep hits it into right for
a base hit
i've seen brett anderson do that that
kid will never forget it yeah it is big
good start right here by tommy edmond
base hit for nolan aronado
[Applause]
now travis shaw he drew a four pitch
walk
in the first inning first and second one
away
waiting on a 3-2
swinging a high fly deep right field my
oh my is that ball crushed
three run home run travis shaw
seven nothing brewers
[Applause]
wow
second home run of the season for travis
shaw this one a three run shot
and dean picks up a base hit into right
carlson
stopping at second base
big gap in right center
and the bases are loaded
[Applause]
so two walks in the inning
ovieno puts it in play slowly hit
and the out and the run scores
johan oviedo first throw it back
drives in a run
they gonna keep that baseball anderson
throws it in and
a souvenir right there for johann oviedo
good job puts ball in play
and drives one in
run it out in front of the plate it's a
fair ball throw to second there double
play oviedo had to hit the deck yachty
almost took his head off
about that play
oviedo and he hit the deck and molina
throws an absolute rocket to second base
watch your lips on this one johanna
hits it that quickly oreos is running at
second
yachty knows he's got time
and this one into center field base hit
for jackie bradley jr
two out single for milwaukee top half of
the six two outs a man on the pitch
swing and a miss a breaking ball away
strikes out garcia
we go to the bottom of the six
of the billikens
little flare out to shallow left that
ball will drop
force play at third and in there safely
bases loaded a five-game hitting streak
for carlson here's austin dean
dean
inside the first base line two runs will
score
dean to second
and here come the cardinals
[Applause]
pitch to
carlson is swinging a miss and box
burger blows him away with a fastball
that's the second out of the inning
nice short hop and a great throw by
robertson there to retire dean
and a good quick one two three inning
for foxborger
there was an opportunity in the eighth
inning to
tag on a run or two and two on in
scoring position
with one down and couldn't get it done
in a nice play
at short but goldschmidt
bobbled the ball
so avi garcia is safe
don't see that very often from
goldschmidt no
go glover over there
all right so runner advances to second
on the out one down now for milwaukee
here in the ninth all right here's manny
pina
pina to left and look at this one fly
way back
manny pina three hit day his first home
run of 2021
and there's some insurance runs for you
it took a while i mean it took a while
to get those add-on runs but manny pena
providing a little bit of
a pop in that bad how about manny a
three-hit day
that pitch swung on and missed 97 mile
an hour fastball
one up and one down in the ninth
and the two one is a base hit into left
right on cue one out hit justin williams
here's the one two
and this one fly ball shallow right
field
jase peterson calling for it makes the
catch and the brewers win this one in
saint louis good victory
for milwaukee here today 9-3 they scored
nine runs in each of the last two games
against st louis yeah the offense has
come to life last couple of games
outstanding
and the brewers able to get some big
offense early